imagine if you had an extra thumb will
the amazing things you would be able to
do like play the guitar faster or eat a
bag of chips with one hand it's
delicious well we went to the University
of Cambridge to find out what amazing
things we could do with
it the third thumb is a 3D printed extra
thumb for your hand that's controlled
with your toes I was really trying to
investigate that relationship between
the wearer and prosthetic I wanted to
feel what it was like to be in control
of something that I was wearing but that
had kind of this proportional control
that was responding to my movements what
I really envisioned for the third fil is
more specific workplaces that then you
do a slight redesign so for example I've
spoken with a shoulder surgeon and he
was really interested in being able to
hold his multiple tools at the same time
rather than collaborate with an
assistant so how did Danny start working
on the third thumb I've always been
interested in designing for the body I
think that's so much more interesting as
a as a products owner and then it wasn't
until uh my masters at the Royal College
B that I really started exploring
Prosthetics I'm not a medical
professional working in Prosthetics uh
in the medical field that is a whole
kind of different area I'm working in
this more exploratory field we're trying
to split it off into prosthetic versus
augmentation and I just kind of see it
all in the same movement we're just
extending the human body an ampute is
completely different to A congenital
one-hander yet societal perception is
that they just have one arm and so
they're they're missing something and
that's not true and so if we start to
try to like Silo this technology like
this is for augmentation and this is for
Prosthetics it's the same technology
we're just talking about how you feel
about that person and also they might
not feel about that themselves is it a
prosthetic is it for someone without a
thumb or is it augmentation for someone
worth two thumbs it's both uh or it's
either and or it totally depends on the
wearer Danny's invention went viral
online which meant her master's project
turned into much more than just that
when it went viral online I thought
that's kind of where it would live in
this online space that people could go
uh or uh you know and and really kind of
spark these discussions and I had just
would have thousands of comments on on
videos and stuff like that of people
going either way or also emailing me and
letting me know their feelings about it
as well and that's where I thought it
would live and then U but now it's uh in
a whole different space could we give it
to our one of our crew
yes absolutely you're crew can try
one cool we're putting a third thumb on
you today so we're going to go through
this one first and then through there
and then just going to turn on your
ankles back to my feet your left foot is
going to control the kind of up and back
and your right foot is is the kind of
dominant foot is going to control the
across and back
and yeah there you go you're doing
great so this is still like first minute
of
use I feel like a natural yeah you look
like a natural should we give you your
first object I'd love to okay so right
and press and
hold at
that how many can you normally pick up
cuz you have quite
large I can hold up three oranges in my
hand I can hold four oranges my hand
with the third thumb
cam
I think that
counts thank
you two
sugars
no it's
delicious should I take a drink oh
no it happens to the best of us so just
so you know we're going to have to put
you in an MRI scanner later oh okay
we're going to be testing your
brain cool and they actually did test my
brain brain so that the activity inside
it when I was using the third thumb
could be studied by Professor Tamar Mak
it's not claustrophobic at all in here
my name is Tamal megin and I'm a
professor of cognitive neuroscience and
my role is to run the lab that we call
the plasticity Lab in Cambridge
University I got this big rant meant to
help me start establishing the first
frontiers of human augmentation
specifically allowing people to have
extra body parts a colleague of mine
told me he just watched this video of
this extra robotic thumb that just looks
amazing I've asked my student who was
running the project at the time if she
can try hunt down this person Danny
Claude and that's how we start working
together the interesting thing about the
body and the brain is that you can't
change one without the other when we're
thinking about adding extra body parts
or replacing body parts we are
immediately implicating the brain if we
could harness this technology in a
thoughtful and responsible way we could
really offer an incredible new
opportunity for Humanity to improve
productivity since coming to Cambridge
University how much has Danny's vision
of the third thumb changed the
fundamentals from the first prototype
are definitely the same I certainly
didn't think it would be so similar
which I'm so quite impressed with and
managed to to like make it good the
first time when the neuroscientists like
kind of Started collaborating With Me on
it I thought that they'd get rid of the
foot control pretty quickly but it has
lasted because is it works so well we
had almost 600 participants come and try
the third thumb for the first time and
then we asked them to do a task within a
minute 98% of people could could use the
third thumb within the first minute
which is really important for pieces of
Technology like this so how's my brain
activity looking tomorrow my clever
students have processed the information
that the machine has gathered and we can
look and see what happens when St uses
the thumb and what we find is that the
brain areas that control the foot and
control the hand they light up once he's
using his third thumb over a longer
period of time we might start seeing
changes where the brain
reconfiguratron he has a beautiful uh
activity in the right place to the right
amount he has a wonderful brain activity
oh thank goodness for
that Danny is a rock star to me I work
with so many gifted people so smart so
talented Danny is all of that but she's
also uh able to combine wonderful
creativity with practicality which is a
very complex combination to
achieve I don't don't don't think I'd be
doing this if I only collaborated with
other designers I'm collaborating with
neuroscientists and anthropologists and
engineers and artists and that's what
kind of makes this work so Dynamic I'm
constantly surprised that I'm still
working on the third thumb I'm I'm
amazed that this thing that I made uh
during my master's degree is now being
used for phds in neuroscience at
Cambridge University that's so mad to me
and so inspiring and keeps pushing me
forward to make it
better
feel the signups is firing in your mind
I I did feel like the sign upses were
popping uh in my mind they were moving
crazy
[Laughter]